the right-hander godly good time out
last last time four innings nothing so
the bases are loaded
one out for joey wendell
and a ground ball down the first bobble
by chavis it's it is mitt it's stuck in
the webbing of that mid he was trying to
dig it out
trying to go home with a throw and could
not dislodge the baseball he can't even
make the play he's trying to cut off
that runner at the plate
and maybe try to look to get a three six
or three two three double play
can't get the ball out of the glove the
ray's got a first inning run and how
about that blake snell making his fourth
start of the season just eight total
innings so far he's gone two three and
three he would love to get to five
innings tonight they're talking five
innings 75 pitches maybe whichever comes
first
at first representing the tag run and
there's rafael devers
on the ground for two out at second and
outed first four six three on the double
play started by wendell how about that
now you're just averaging six pitches
per hit the rays have a one to nothing
lead so here's willie to lead things off
as there's a swing and a fly ball out
toward right center field and deep back
out of bradley jr to the triangle but
it's gone into the home bullpen willia
dominus with his first home run of 2020
and he's given a raise a two-nothing
lead here in the second the base is
empty for austin meadows
now the two one and that skied into the
right
went back now he comes in and it's gonna
be bradley jr to make the pickup to get
the ball back into second
and pilar
apparently lost that ball metal saw not
enough of it not to be happy right
and now here is lao getting into one and
that baby is out of here brandon lau
with his second hit of the night jumping
all over that first pitch
home run number four
and the raise
with two more runs to make it four to
nothing their second home run of the
inning with one out that'll bring up
christian vasquez now the 2-2 pitch is
on its way elevated fastball and he just
blew him away
strike three as vasquez swings right
through it and there is out number two
here in the second davis in at second
base with his first stolen base of the
year beginning its way in the dirt swung
and missed strike three perez able to
smother it and make sure that verdugo
gets tagged out and he does that and
that'll do it for boston
the hitter is going to be chasugo
and this one he lifts into deep right
that baby is gone
home run over the bullpen on the first
pitch
yoshi satsugo
it's his second home run of the year
for the raise tonight they're third
in as many innings and they lead
six nothing
jose barraza lines one towards the left
field corner giving a chase and a dive
and making the catch is yoshi tatsugo
that's his best defensive play since
joining the rays diving in front of the
monster and he pounds his chest and he's
fighting back a smile second and third
infield halfway all the way around
and through the left side of base hit
meadows scores
diaz comes through with a base hit
the rays now lead
seven nothing
ryan weber he finally gets in runners at
first and third they belong to
godley's account
on the ground right side
bogarts won first base
they get
the double play and lau crosses the
plate
so the rays make it an eight-run ball
game
perez is over three he's kind of lucky
he's standing after the night he's had
[Applause]
it's eight nothing tampa bay so four
singles in a row get the red sox their
first run of the night
[Music]
ball he jacks that one deep to left and
it is gone
a grand slam j.d martinez with his
second home run of the season he makes
it an eight to five game let's see if
the rays can make some adjustments
the breaking ball lifted in the air
right field and deep polar going back
bradley jr going back to the bullpen
it's gone
into the red sox bullpen it lands austin
meadows it's his first home run of the
season and the rays are back up by a
score of nine to five
a towering home run
by austin meadows a little backspin to
it bradley jr and pilar both got to that
small wall out there in right center
field and bradley jr was thinking about
trying to go over top and
he almost flipped over and almost did
the tory hunter right there but it's the
boston cop too yeah